-You're on the
House Intelligence Committee.
You've been dealing a lot with
the Russian investigation.
So, I'm happy you're here, but I
don't think Donald Trump is.
He tweeted about you recently.
And right here we see,
"Sleazy Adam Schiff,
the totally biased Congressman
looking into Russia,
spends all of his time
on television..."
so he's got you there.
[ Laughter ]
"...pushing
the Dem loss excuse."
So, when you first saw that,
from the president
of the United States,
how did you feel?
-Well, I was getting on
the plane to fly to Washington,
and my phone
lit up with messages.
"The president
just called you a sleaze."
-Uh-huh.
-And my reaction was,
"I've been slimed."
-Yeah.
-Like a character
on "Ghostbusters."
-You did.
-But my second reaction was,
he really should've talked
to my friends from grade school.
-Yeah.
-With a name like Schiff, they
did much better than he did.
There was a lot of material
to work with there.
-Yeah, he usually does
a really good with his, like,
disparaging nicknames.
But I feel like
he dropped the ball.
-It was a missed opportunity.
-I feel like
you're making him so angry
that you're blinding his ability
to really dig in.
[ Laughter ]
-This is true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I want to talk about
The Wall Street Journal
reported tonight
that Special Counsel Mueller
has opened up a grand jury.
Now, you have
a different investigation.
You're the House Intelligence
Committee's investigation.
There's a
Senate Judiciary Committee.
Senate Intelligence Committee.
The grand jury is separate,
but what can --
What does this tell you,
as somebody
with your legal background,
that he has opened up
a grand jury?
-Well, his responsibility
is really different
than all of ours in Congress,
because we're looking at
the whole range
of what Russia did,
their active measures campaign,
what tactics they employed.
He's looking
at a very specific task,
and that is,
were U.S. laws violated,
and if so,
who should be prosecuted?
And the fact that he has now
apparently, or reportedly,
gone to a grand jury
means he now needs
the power of compulsion
to get documents
to compel witnesses to testify.
That is a necessary step
to move forward
to a potential prosecution.
Doesn't mean
that he will prosecute.
But this is
part of an investigation
very much moving forward.
-And another report said
that he's sort of moving into
the financial element of this.
Donald Trump had said recently,
in speaking about
Special Counsel Mueller,
that that was sort of
a red line for him.
Why do you think it is
that Donald Trump
is so worried about
the financial part
of this investigation?
-Well, I'll tell you why
I'm so concerned about it,
and that is, when people think
about kompromat,
what the Russians call
"compromising material,"
they tend to think about
the dossier,
potentially salacious videos.
-It's all I think about.
[ Laughter ]
I wish you hadn't brought it up.
-The far more compromising
material would be
if the Russians were engaged,
as they do in other places,
like Europe,
in illicit
financial transactions
and money laundering
or something like that
with the Trump organization.
Then, they would have very
powerful compromising material
they could hold over his head,
and it could affect U.S. policy.
So if Bob Mueller
is looking into this,
you know,
it's really quite necessary
to make sure
that our policy is based
on U.S.
national security interests,
not the personal exposure of the
president of the United States.
And, obviously, this deeply
worries the president.
Now, whether that says something
about his financial dealings
in the past remains to be seen,
but plainly,
this is what got him,
once again, to talk about
possibly removing Mueller.
-Now, you were talking about,
"Did the Russians do anything
to compromise
the Trump administration,
Donald Trump personally?"
And this is interesting,
because the Russians,
you could find
in your investigation
that the Russians did things,
and it turns out
that the Trumps
were not aware of this.
And Jared Kushner
sort of made that argument --
it was in a leaked audio --
to Congressional interns
that we couldn't have
colluded with the Russians.
He basically said,
"We couldn't even collude
with our own campaign."
Like, basically, making
an argument of incompetence.
Which isn't a bad argument.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, and the speaker has often
made the same argument.
-Yes.
-You know, "Don't hold
the president responsible.
He doesn't know
what he's doing."
-"He's new."
-Yeah.
-"He's inexperienced.
He's not a politician."
-All things that would've
been great to hear
on the campaign trail, yeah.
-Yes. Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I want to ask this,
as well.
I'm imagining that you have
a lot of people that see you
and see your investigation
as some sort of savior
for the Democratic party.
Like, this, you're gonna
discover something
that's gonna
push him out of office.
It strikes me that the Democrats
are at risk right now,
as a party,
of putting too much stock
in hoping that an investigation
brings about the end
of the Trump administration
when the focus should be
at where you hope
administrations end --
at the ballot box.
Do you think the Democratic
party is doing enough messaging
outside of their investigations
into the Trump administration,
as far as,
"Hey, the next time you vote,
we actually have a message
that is independent
of what we think is wrong with
the current people in power"?
-You know, this is, I think,
absolutely essential,
and that is, yes, we have do go
forward with the investigation,
and that's very important
for the reasons we talked about,
but more than that, we need
to give voters a positive --
a powerful positive reason
to vote for Democrats,
not just all the reasons
they don't like Donald Trump,
which they know already.
And I think
the real key to that
is addressing the economic
concerns that people have,
particularly
in distressed communities
where they look
at a small global world.
They look at automation
replacing a lot of jobs,
and they ask, and they have
every right to ask,
"What are you offering us
to give us hope
that our lives can be better,
that our children's lives
can be better?"
They have every right
to ask that.
We need to have
a good answer for them.
The Republicans
have no answer except,
"You're gonna win so much,
you're gonna be
tired of winning."
Well, they're
not tired of winning.
-No.
-But we owe them
a good answer, too,
and we are working on it.
It's, I think, not only vital
to the Democratic party,
it's vital to the country.
If we're gonna have
a situation where we continue
to pass on
to the next generation
a higher quality of life,
we're gonna have to answer
that very difficult
but very important
economic question.
-I look forward to seeing --
hearing what those answers are
from the party.
Last thing -- every day --
I pay attention to this stuff
every day.
The part of me
that can be shocked --
I keep waiting to be numbed --
but every day,
something happens
where I go, "What?!"
Does that still happen for you?
-Every day it happens.
-Okay.
-It --
-All right.
It's nice to see
you're not jaded.
-I like to say I'm running out
of adjectives and expletives.
-Well, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
We have to start --
Yeah, we have to find
more of those for this.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Really appreciate it.
-Thank you.
-Congressman Adam Schiff,
everybody!